so remember Isis what happened to them
at Sunday's New York Times rod Nordland
writes about a thousand Isis dirtbags
surrendering to Kurdish authorities yes
this is huge Kimberly I remember when
martyrdom was their only option now
these so-called warriors meekly give up
why now it's not hard to figure out the
only way to beat Isis was to disprove
the thesis that an Islamic state was
inevitable and to do that was through
humiliating crushing defeats the only
reason why Isis was around so long was
that we wouldn't do that and their
grisly propaganda proceeded unabated
persuading entire cities to flee instead
of fight the longer we waited you saw it
the worse it got
but coming at them bombing the crap out
of them killing everyone they know it
seems to work who would have thought oh
yeah president Trump it's something for
which he gets no credit he literally
he's literally ending Isis it won't be
the end of jihadism but for now the
dreams of a state are over their terrain
is shrinking sometimes a full frontal
assault is the most strategic idea and
it beats Obama's dithering all that ever
got us was the paralysis of analysis so
laugh all you want about the tired
phrase there's a new sheriff in town
I think Isis got that message and while
we have to be careful of the mission
accomplished' syndrome what is
undeniable is that Isis is off the front
pages and on their last legs one hopes
Kim jong-un is watching yes I wrapped it
all up indeed Jesse what do you think
big news no one's Carrie because
everything else is covering it up I
agree I mean Isis the strategy is taking
hold that Trump said in Saudi Arabia
that he was going to have these Muslims
drive them out and they are so it's the
Kurdish military the Arab militias and
the Iraqi forces they've now toppled
three strongholds Mosul tella fire and
hawea Rock is now the last stronghold
it's surrounded at this point yep it
could fall by the end of the year we
learned some valuable lessons here one
Isis fighters cowards - loosening the
rules of engagement letting boots on the
ground do their job and then fighting
them instead of containing them is
actually an effective strategy and the
Iraqi military has come a long
way since when Bush trained them
remember those little videos where they
were like hopping over things that's
gone these guys are doing a great job we
also learned that everything President
Obama said about Isis was wrong he said
more boots on the ground was going to
enflame the situation he said more US
presence there was going to bog us down
into a quagmire and he also said there
needed to be a political solution before
there was a military solution turns out
the military solution came first and
it's working what I would like to see
though as I would like to see more
camera teams embedded in some of these
battle fields because then the American
people can see you for sacrifices
you know volunteering no but you know
here's the thing
here's my theory yeah but why there are
no cameras there because we are killing
everything and they don't want to show
it and they're doing it in a way that
might be experimental they might be
using stuff that like drones and stuff
that we don't know about so that's why I
think we're not seeing a damn thing and
by the way I think you have no problem
with that because I think you want the
the end result in the outcome drum yes
absolutely you always are and what I
think is important in Jesse you touched
on this is the Kurdish pesh MERGA what
an elite fighting force and they have
really done a tremendous job along with
their allies and like you said it's
pretty much only Raqqa and they have
them contained in little pockets in
Raqqa so I think they just wipe them out
all the way so they're not even JV team
like Obama used to come claim but the
the interesting part is all of these
members of Isis these fighters that are
surrendering okay the ones that aren't
they're going into Afghanistan to try to
fight the US and Western forces there so
keep an eye on that and that's hence the
escalation and and doing more you know
troops and stuff in forces in
Afghanistan to help combat that but
where are all the Isis guys that are
surrendering going to go who is going to
take care and control of them and are
they going to be released back out into
Europe where they can continue being
radicalized or join with other groups or
have cells and pockets to in fact commit
other acts of terror so I think that's a
really important piece Gitmo
send them to Gitmo well put another put
another floor on it / - that's right one
why hasn't President Trump
awarded the Nobel Prize for this because
he clearly deserves this use your modern
day not to know these look I can't tell
you I am all for the decimation of Isis
go for it but remember when you said
let's not say mission accom
everything in fact Kimberly just
pointing this out what's gonna happen
inside of Syria we don't know nothing
right nothing sir Oh Jesse says
additional truth no really we put a few
more specific trainers and fighters on
the ground to work with Iraqi forces and
especially Kurdish forces guess what the
Turks don't want anything to do and
guess what the Iraqis say the United
States by supporting the Kurdish forces
is dividing their country and contrary
to their interest and interfering their
domestic affairs a further point here
okay well I don't want to just come in
and be a downer so the good news first
is that Greg is right yeah major
military victories on the ground in Iraq
and Syria against Isis undeniably and
they cannot have a state any legitimate
claims to statehood without land okay
now are you ready for the bad news
okay you're gonna get it anyway the bad
news is that the battlefield is no
longer in Iraq and Syria the battlefield
has migrated into cyberspace the
battlefield today four years into this
battle is now largely online and while
we are denying them safe havens while we
are killing their forces they're still
they are attracting more and faster than
ever before online and that is that's
where this part about combating the
ideology comes in and that's a point
where President Obama was right
President Trump is right everybody come
continues to point this out again Adam
we're not very good at combating that so
we need we have major strides to go
before we can declare mission
accomplished unfortunately I wish we
could declare I just think killing and
killing them is a good thing it's a
great thing
that's why I started with a good news
well that's the Robin by the way the
majority of them that are captured like
hey yeah my bad I was just with Isis on
I'm actually a really good cook I just
want to go work and live in America at
McDonald's they should put them in front
of the stove and be like all right whip
something up isn't that funny you are
far more forgiving than I am we shoot
him in the head yeah